frogs and toads jump swim climb even  glide but for strange species of  amphibians prefer to walk the Senegal  running frog the bumblebee toad the red  banded rubber frog and the tiger leg  monkey frog don't walk like dogs or  other four-legged beasts instead they  crawl low to the ground they stretch  their front legs out while crouching  their back legs the walking frogs front  legs are a bit shorter than their hind  legs but they compensate for this with  their stooping gait in the typical frog  the difference between front and back  leg length is more extreme the  researchers still don't know why the  frogs prefer walking to hopping but all  four species live in similar grassland  habitats that lack branches or foliage  to latch on to so it may be a better  idea to slink away then jump when  predators are near evolution hasn't  entirely ruined the essence of these  species frog nests though one researcher  says that the frogs can still jump and  swim they just usually don't